so what about the opposite what if
someone says well I'm never gonna get
notes like that I'm gonna have it packed
with conflict and then it's actually too
much it's not subtle it's not under the
surface like I'm just thinking of sharp
objects I watched the first episode last
night and you can see seeds planted that
the conflict some of it's obvious some
of it's not and you're wondering hmm
there was a look at the end with this
one character I think there's gonna you
know and I like hints at it and then it
keeps you hooked in because you're like
I want to see something go down here but
it doesn't yet yeah well I mean yeah
it's like it's not that you have to hit
over hit people over the head with with
constant like you know screaming matches
or fights or anything like that to me
it's that there has to be a central
problem and a central character faced
with that problem that the audience buys
into early on and says okay I care about
this problem I want to see this problem
get solved for this person by this
person once you have them feeling that
way then you can play out the resolution
of that problem over a lengthy period of
time you don't have to get right to it
in a really you know sledgehammer kind
of manner but the the problem has to be
big enough to begin with it has to be
grabby enough to begin with then how
they evolved in dealing with the problem
and how the problem evolved and if it's
a mystery how the cards get turned over
and the clues get revealed and the leads
get followed up on that's part of the
fun for the audience is that that stuff
takes time you just don't want to have
long periods where none of that's
happening at all and things seem kind of
fine that's what you want to avoid
things are never fine in a story there's
always that simmering you know problem
overshadowing everything I think in a
compelling commercial story where the
audience is going I want to see this
resolved the reason I'm binging on this
is I want to see this problem or these
problems get resolved but what they
really want to see is they want to see
how the problems build and complicated
twist and turn and evolve and then later
get resolved because you know once it
gets resolved it's kind of over so if
you're binging on twelve episodes or
whatever it is you probably know no real
resolution gonna happen till the end of
the twelfth if then but on the way how
its evolving
the thing that's fun for us to watch as
an audience have you given notes to
someone to hate tone it down this is too
much right here it's too explosive and
it's like almost like beating the the
the reader over the head a little bit I
don't think that happens very much
unless what they're doing doesn't feel
believable to me that's the sort of the
be--and problem is you know believable
and and that's a bigger more common
issue than people might think where
readers are reading their stuff and
going I don't believe this character
would do or say this or maybe it doesn't
it feels contrived in some way it feels
like the writer is trying to force
something that isn't organically coming
out of the lives and desires and
emotions and personalities of the
characters so on to some extent the
characters do have to drive the story
everything they're doing has to feel
like it could and would really happen
they could or would really say or do
those things in those moments so it's
not that I'm ever saying oh there's too
much conflict you're trying to make the
problem too big per se and less in doing
that it's straining believability
because even though stories have easily
something exaggerated about them or even
sometimes a fantastical element that
they're based on like there's a zombie
apocalypse or there's vampires in the
high school or whatever even though they
have that kind of stuff sometimes and
even in a comedy you're exaggerating
characters a little bit for comedy I
believe there still has to be this basis
of reality that we're seeing human
beings that we can accept seem real
doing or saying what we think they would
really do or say in those situations and
a lot of times in a lot of scripts there
will be moments and scenes and
characters that don't feel that way that
feel over-the-top unbelievable reacting
in ways that seem forced for the sake of
more conflict or more comedy or
entertainment value or more action so
that's where I might sometimes feel that
something needs to be toned down so that
it feels like it's all coming from a
real place when in doubt always I say go
for the real I heard somebody say this
once a professional writer at at a panel
and it's so true you hope that your
concept is compelling enough people are
going to care there's something
entertaining at its core but as you
start plot
get out I always say start with what's
real at every moment in the story what
would each character be really thinking
feeling doing at this point given their
situation how do you make them do things
that feel totally believable and just
totally real audiences love it when it
feels real but still is entertaining and
compelling and all those other things
and achieving that level of realness
that feels really authentic is is
difficult but it's really special when a
writer is able to just write with like
authenticity that is just like I
absolutely suspend disbelief you
absolutely have me I believe these
people are real I forget that I'm
watching something fictional so when you
can do that in the context of having
these other elements of a story then I
think you're really in good shape can
you think of a film in particular that
there was like one of the first that did
that for you well I mean I think most
really great and successful movies and
TV shows do have reality do you have
that basis of reality which is why they
work if they didn't have it I don't
think they'd be successful so I think
you see that in most successful things
that there is that sense of I believe
these people and what they're doing I
believe the reality the situation's the
writer has set up having said that there
are certain shows certain movies that I
can think of maybe not the first that
did it but that feel they did it to a
really extreme level like the wire on
HBO that series you know to me kind of
made every other cop show that it ever
come before seemed almost kind of like
cheesy or fake in comparison because it
felt so real and when you can achieve
that level of realness audiences critics
agents producers they all respond to
that if you have these other kind of
elements of story in place that level of
realness can really make your stuff
special so that's one example The
Sopranos was also a show that even
though it was a was entrain to be as
real as the wire when I would watch The
Sopranos I would kind of like just buy
it for some reason that was a show that
I felt like I don't feel like I'm
watching actors and writers and
directors I feel like I'm watching these
like real people that are really living
in the
subculture at its best which i think is
the reason why shows like The Sopranos
and The Wire are voted like some of the
best written shows of all time because
they obviously did that for a lot of
people or even Forrest Gump I mean I
could I could think that that is a real
person that if you go on Wikipedia
though oh there he is and I know he's
yes and he beat this person in ping-pong
and I mean it's believable enough as
wild of a ride as his life was that that
could be a real person there's just
something about the the writing and and
drawing you into this sort of innocent
world yeah I mean I think you're right I
mean it's yeah it's a very opposite
example where it's a very fanciful story
but somehow it convinces the audience
for those 2 to 3 hours that this is a
real thing and nothing is making them go
okay it's not real anymore I don't get I
mean there are people who don't like the
movie but I don't think there's much
that makes people just check out because
it doesn't seem like it could be
plausible you know the characters once
you establish who they are they behave
in ways that make sense based on who
they are and what their psychology and
their backstories are and what their
current desires and situations are and
that's where it's like the writer Eric
Roth in this case is going for the real
I think is taking you know the situation
the people where they're at and saying
what is real to have happen next and
plus he's throwing in some very damaged
supporting characters you know Jenny and
Captain Dan and things like that around
it and so as perfect as Forrest might
seem and that he kind of just is always
able to you know run through no pun
intended sort of situations he has some
very sort of damaged people around them
that are very real and that that part is
also interesting yeah I mean I think if
you look at Lieutenant Dan or Jenny in
Forrest Gump they are they are playing
out their psychology their family
history their wounds their problems
their worst tragedies that have happened
to them and they feel like it's
psychologically real and that's what I
mean when I say real it's like
psychologically based on who they are I
think a writer kind of a fiction kind of
has to be a little bit of a psychologist
because you're saying given this
person's history
what they've been through how would they
be now how would they react in this
situation how would they go about
pursuing whatever they want in their
lives and you know it's gonna vary
greatly based on where they come from
and what led them to this point so yeah
it's not it's not easy to do that really
well but when you do I think audiences
respond by totally buying in and being
compelled by this psychologically real
feeling person that you're putting on
screen or on the page
you